well students say they don't feel safe
teachers are quitting parents demanding
answers eight news now has shed light on
violence inside our schools and now
governor steve sisilak is weighing in on
the issue the 8 news now i-team's
vanessa murphy joins us with more on her
one-on-one interview with the governor
vanessa kirsten and bryan governor
siselek seemingly calling out school
district leaders like the school board
for failing to take appropriate action
to address violence in schools to be
clear the governor doesn't oversee the
clark county school district or any
other districts but he does oversee the
nevada department of education he points
to the estimated 5 thousand reported
violent incidents at ccs schools during
the current school year recently ccsd
superintendent dr jesus jarrah announced
there will be stiffer consequences for
students responsible for violence like
expulsion and that teachers would have
access to panic buttons here's what
governor siselek told me earlier today
there has to be a consequence a swift
immediate firm consequence for these
actions because people should not be in
jeopardy so are you saying
you believe those consequences aren't
happening right now i don't believe
they're happening right now no i don't
believe they're quick enough i don't
believe they're firm enough and i
believe it's putting teachers in a real
tough vulnerable position you know that
they
have trouble controlling you know
students
now the governor actually sat down with
us to specifically talk about his health
care provider summit tomorrow which will
be live streamed we'll have a link for
you at 8newsnow.com but we tried to get
in some additional questions and address
other topics like school violence as you
heard him there the health and human
services secretary will join him
tomorrow to make an announcement about a
mental health initiative and the
governor wants to address other issues
affecting our state one of them is
nevada's severe nursing shortage he says
the pandemic really highlighted that
back to you